let me ask you a few questions but I'm
gonna hit you first an easy one what's
the difference between multi clout and
hybrid cloud it's a really good question
Dan
so hybrid cloud traditionally refers to
running some part of your workload
on-premise and some part in a public
cloud but usually that means one and
only one public cloud possibly tied or
locked to that particular vendor
multi-cloud means having the flexibility
to run in one or more different public
clouds
perhaps switching between them depending
on cost or other reasons
well considering acquisitions are
happening so much today's you could have
a multi cloud simply by the very fact
that you acquired someone right right
speaking of acquisitions we've had one
at IBM the big news for IBM was the
acquisition of Red Hat how has that
affected IBM's cloud strategy going
forward well I think the single biggest
thing is that we are leveraging the open
shift kubernetes platform as a delivery
vehicle for all of our software by our
IBM cloud pack strategy so all of our
cloud packs including the cloud pack for
multi cloud management are delivered on
top of OpenShift
our cloud pack for applications actually
allows customers to build applications
to run on top of OpenShift
so that's really the biggest piece we
have lots of other bits where we are
bringing components of Red Hat together
with both our management portfolio and
other portfolios but the biggest is
openshift I'd say gotcha
well Red Hat is a big fan of open source
so as IBM has open source tools like
monitoring and management I know they're
big fans like we mentioned but what role
does open source playing the cloud pack
for multi cloud management we've seen
what red had fun with open source right
as you mentioned right they've done a
great job of providing enterprise grade
support and updates around an open
source set of communities mm-hm
iBM has had a similar relationship with
open source and we look to continue that
with the cloud pack for multi cloud
management so leveraging both the open
source capabilities that come in from
Red Hat and open source communities such
as kubernetes that are outside of that
and Prometheus and Griffin o Elk other
sorts of things like that we'll look to
expand our open source involvement and
really follow Red Hat's lead they're
really they've had the lead in
in this particular space but have a
whole big stack that is based upon open
source and then the enterprise support
on top of it we're gonna be working more
and more with Red Hat as years go on
yeah arguably though development shops
have multiple cloud platforms it's the
new norm why wouldn't cuss tumors also
use multiple vendor tools to manage and
maintain their environments so what we
find is if you use multiple clouds you
end up with multiple tool sets from each
of those individual clouds and if you
stick with just those tool sets from the
different cloud vendors you end up with
multiple panes of glass and multiple
places that need to go and check so in
the case of something like security it's
really easy for something to slip
through the cracks and your ops teams
are gonna be upset by that
absolutely so having a single control
plane that sits in front of those cloud
tools really gives you that visibility
and governance and and across your
entire environment so you have multiple
cloud platforms that you have a single
view on and that doesn't eliminate the
need for those tools on those multiple
cloud providers you still may drill down
to those but having some layer that's
above that that is that single control
point really is critical let's go down
one level now we know that kubernetes
manages containers VMware and OpenStack
manages VMs does the cloud pack for
multi cloud management help manage these
non container workloads - one of the
things that we found is we've discussed
with clients since we've been on this
multi cloud management journey for the
last couple years is that while cloud
native architectures with containers are
the hot new thing it represents a pretty
small percentage of what customers have
in their environments today virtual
machines make up the vast majority of
that there's something like 80% it's
more than it's probably even more than
80 90% and then there's some bare metal
stuff mainframes etc right the ability
to have your multi cloud management
platform handle all of those resources
even as your modernization journey might
take you to more containers in the next
three five ten years is a really
critical thing and it's a design point
for us with the cloud pack for multi
cloud management meet the client where
they are today in terms of their
infrastructure and be able to grow with
them as they modernize and maybe change
that blend in the future I mean they've
made a huge investment you're lying
that investment absolutely and if you
look outside of our clawed back for
multi cloud management to someplace like
our cloud pack for applications we can
also help them modernize that
application layer that's running on top
of it as well so we really are looking
at the cloud pack for multi cloud
management is helping them modernize
that management layer while at the same
time the development teams are
modernizing that application list
beginner development teams you know we
talked a lot about the ops teams and
we've talked about the dev team is the
multi cloud compliance the security is
that a concern for development for
operations or both of them have to worry
about this now I think the answer is
both but I think traditionally the
answer has been it's primarily been an
operations problem and security has been
something that has been a bolt-on or an
afterthought once you've pushed the
application interpret or the developer
has to worry about it too well when they
have to fix the bugs of course right
you're seeing an emerging practice in
the industry called dev SEC ops which
really if you think about it brings that
together development security operations
right and really what that means is
you're injecting security and policy and
compliance practices into the
development lifecycle from the beginning
right it's an extension of DevOps and
agile practices so DevOps would have you
inject things like monitoring from day
one dev set cop says well in addition to
adding monitoring and management from
day one you need that security too so
the two teams have to work together
absolutely absolutely and again I think
you'll probably see a new term come out
some point which is the security focused
sre right because again that's very
similar those practices of bringing
those things together and not have them
be separate silos so how does the cloud
pack for multi cloud management make it
easier to enforce those policies
ensuring that safe and compliant
environment I mean that's about making
the ops team more efficient absolutely
right and also providing something that
the development team can develop to them
so we've picked up some concepts from
kubernetes and that's a notion of a
declarative model where you write out in
code or in a text document what you want
the compliance to be in the form of a
policy is very kubernetes like isn't it
yeah an assistant will enforce that for
you so what that means is our developers
can write that as a piece of code with
their application they can check it into
source control it can go over to the ops
team the ops team can
pull that out and deploy it into
production so it's now completely a part
of that dev SEC ops process because you
have that declarative model right again
it's building off of what kubernetes is
done but really stretching that out to
those non container resources as well
gotcha so if I'm adopting this cloud
model here how does security and
compliance become critical to that
deployment success well I would say you
want to start right away with security
when you when you when you adopt it's
it's a critical component I would say
that traditionally speaking we've always
had it as at the end of the process once
we get to production let's worry about
let's put intrusion detection and
vulnerability detection and all that
stuff on it there's tripwire systems on
the production environment but what
we're realizing is particularly in this
world where we're bringing in more open
source components and using public cloud
services that you really need to be as
soon as you start developing these
components you need to start worrying
about security of the system checking
the security of the system even if it's
in your development builds like if it's
a micro services won't it be a component
that you can then put a wrapper around
absolutely it absolutely is and that
micro service you might develop and
think it's only gonna run on premise but
then the company may decide oh I'm gonna
run it on a public cloud so I have that
flexibility Yeah right but you still
need to have that ability to have
security which is why you need to be
thinking about that from really when you
first start writing that design document
right even before you even start writing
code secured you need to be part of that
problem you can test it independently
component by component yep absolutely
got it so can you talk about how IBM
Cloud pact management integrates with a
customer's existing tools and process
whether it's from IBM or another vendor
when we walk into a client site they've
got management in place they're running
applications they're running
infrastructure their business is going
on there's no green fields in eyeteeth
where nobody's doing anything yet
there's stuff that's running and they
have to manage it somehow so these can
be things like everyone's got a service
desk somewhere something like a
ServiceNow where they're getting tickets
in often there's some level of
monitoring and log management that
exists in that environment whether it's
an open source tool or a third-party
tool or an IBM tool to solve that
problem we can integrate those in to the
cloud pack for multi cloud management so
that's think
control plane can get events and data
and incidents from all of those
different tools and you have the
flexibility to choose in some cases the
IBM tool or stick with your existing
tool in the case that there might be an
overlap between those two things we
really don't want to present the cloud
pack for multi cloud management as a
monolith that you must consume the whole
thing it's really a set of modular
capabilities that are meant to plug in
with what you already had and build that
control plan between everything
well thanks Matt for taking the time to
talk with us we look forward to hearing
more from you in our next presentation
absolutely thank you so much
you